[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sportplatz
schauen wir auf die Nachrichtenthemen
von heute
Bildungsgipfel wird zum Streit Gipfel
viele bleiben fern andere fordern dass
der Kanzler die Bildung zur Chefsache
Macht
von allem zu wenig sagt die
werbeauftragte über die Bundeswehr vom
Sondervermögen sei noch kein Cent bei
der Truppe angekommen
erschütterndes Verbrechen die
zwölfjährige luise ist offenbar von zwei
fast gleichaltrigen Mädchen erstochen
worden beide haben gestanden
[Musik]
zwei Tage Bildungsgipfel in Berlin damit
will die zuständige Ministerin stark
Watzinger einen neuen Impuls setzen
allerdings haben fast alle ihre Kollegen
und Kolleginnen aus den Ländern aus
Protest abgesagt und ein starkes Bündnis
aus Stiftungen Verbänden und
Gewerkschaften fordert direkt einen
Gipfel mit dem Bundeskanzler die Misere
an den Schulen ist riesig es fehlen
Zehntausende von Lehrern Viertklässler
können mitunter weder richtig lesen noch
rechnen jedes Jahr verlassen
zehntausende Jugendliche die Schule ohne
Abschluss dazu kommt zum Teil eine
desolate Ausstattung Stichwort
Turnhallen und Toiletten und der
digitale Umbau des Unterrichts verläuft
mehr als schleppend hübscher
es ist eine Blamage für die
Bundesbildungsministerin aus den Ländern
sind nur die Berliner Bildungssenatorin
und ihr Hamburger Kollege der Einladung
gefolgt viele Stühle bleiben leer als
stark Watzinger ihren Bildungsgipfel
eröffnet mit der altbekannten
Zustandsbeschreibung wir sind nicht da
wo wir sein müssen und wo wir sein
wollen wir brauchen eine
bildungspolitische Trendwende und
beginnen wir sie doch auch gemeinsam
einer von denen die gar nicht erst nach
Berlin gefahren sind ist der
Kultusminister aus Sachsen er begründet
seine Absage so wir machen das nicht
ohne dass wir nicht eine konkrete Agenda
haben sondern nur eine lapidare
Einladung zu einem sogenannten
Bildungsgipfel wo die Themen nicht klar
sind wo die Zielstellungen wenig klar
ist und ich hätte mir da schon von der
Bundesbildungsministerin erwartet dass
sie so etwas besser vorbereitet nicht
mit dem Tisch Sitz
en ich glaube das ist das falsche Signal
auch an dieser Gesamtschule in
Nordrhein-Westfalen müssen jede Woche
viele Unterrichtsstunden ausfallen und
die Schulleiterin fühlt sich von der
Politik nicht genug gehört die Gebäude
das ist die eine Sache aber das fehlende
Personal ist die andere Sache wenn man
das nicht jeden Tag sieht und miterlebt
wird einem glaube ich ähm nicht klar was
hier wirklich fehlt und ich glaube das
ist es einfach man ist zu weit weg von
der Realität die FDP Ministerin winkt
heute ab als die SPD einen 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen für Bildung
fordert Frust bei Gipfel Teilnehmern was
mich am meisten ärgert ist tatsächlich
dass die große Aufbruchstimmung die ja
da war im Ampel Vertrag wir machen einen
neuen bildungsaufbruch dass die komplett
verloren gegangen ist einziges Ergebnis
dieser Veranstaltung bisher eine
bundländer Task Force soll gegründet
werden und heißen soll sie Teambildung
in Berlin wie berechtigt ist die Kritik
an dem Gipfel und der Ministerin
und ich glaube es ist wie so oft die
Kritik ist einerseits berechtigt und
gleichzeitig bedauerlich kurz gesprungen
berechtigt ist die Kritik weil ein
blockierter Bildungsgipfel eine
verschenkte Chance ist und solche
Veranstaltungen und ja auch die
einhergehende Aufmerksamkeit die kann
nicht ständig einberufen werden
angesichts der Dramatik der
Bildungsprobleme und angesichts der
dringend nötigen Verbesserungen hat Frau
stark Watzinger hier der Sache eher ein
Bären Dienst erwiesen gleichzeitig aber
müssen sich die fernen gebliebenen
Bildungsminister und Ministerinnen der
ländervorwerfen lassen dass sie die
unzureichende Gipfel Vorbereitung
politisch genutzt haben um die
Bundesbildungsministerin durch Blockade
zu blamieren und der Ruf nach einem
Sondergipfel mit dem Kanzler und den
Ministerpräsidenten der hat auch etwas
unreife wenn ein System so marode und
zugleich so wichtig ist dann muss doch
alles für Verbesserung getan werden auch
auf der Ebene der Bildungsminister und
auch auf einem schlecht vorbereitenden
Gipfel
die Einschätzung unseres
hauptstadtkorrespondenten danke schön
nicht nur bei den Schulen in Deutschland
liegt vieles im Argen auch die Kasernen
in der Bundeswehr sind in erbärmlichem
Zustand sagt Eva Högl die werbeauftragte
des Bundestags zu wenige Panzer zu wenig
naxwuchs zu wenige Boote und Flugzeuge
und vom 100 Milliarden Euro schweren
Sondervermögen sei noch kein Cent bei
der Truppe angekommen Andreas Huppert
berichtet die Bundeswehr hat von allem
zu wenig
Einsatz der sitzt von der Frau die
wissen muss wie es um die Truppe
bestellt ist Eva Högl werbeauftragte und
damit Stimme der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten auf über 160 Seiten hat sie im
neuesten wehrbericht alle Mängel Sorgen
und Nöte zusammengetragen
unsere Kasernen sind landauf Land ab ich
sage es noch mal so deutlich in einem
erbärmlichen Zustand es fehlt ein
Unterkünften funktionierende Toiletten
saubere Duschen Spinde
hallensportanlagen truppenküchen
Betreuungseinrichtungen Munitionslager
und Waffenkammern und nicht zuletzt auch
WLAN auch die Ankündigung des 100
Milliarden Sondervermögens machts nicht
besser nach Bestellungen und
Neubeschaffungen bleiben weiterhin die
Achillesferse deutscher
Verteidigungspolitik wir haben jetzt ein
Jahr nach der Zeiten wenn der Rede von
Olaf Scholz warum dauert es so lange bis
wir Haubitzen nachbestellen bis wir
Kampf waren seine nachbestellen wir
reden seit vier Jahren über
Munitionsmenge das kann doch alles nicht
wahr sein die Militärhilfe an die
Ukraine hat zusätzliche Löcher in den
Bestand gerissen Panzer Raketenwerfer
Flug Abwehr sind jetzt Mangelware
weiteres großes Problemfeld das Personal
der Truppe fehlt der Nachwuchs bis 2031
soll die Bundeswehr auf 203.000
Soldatinnen und Soldaten wachsen im
letzten Jahr lag die ist Stärke bei
knapp
183.051 auffällig 27% aller Bundeswehr
Berufsanfänger quittieren innerhalb der
Probezeit ihren Dienst ganz entscheidend
halte ich es die Rahmenbedingungen in
der Bundeswehr zu verbessern
materialpersonalinfrastruktur das ist
das ganz entscheidende dann entscheiden
sich Personen auch für die Truppe eine
Bundeswehr im Alarmzustand auch wegen
all der Mängel das hat der wehrbericht
wieder einmal eindringlich vor Augen
geführt
aufhorchen lässt ein Zwischenfall über
dem Schwarzen Meer offenbar ist ein
russischer Kampfjet mit einer
unbemannten amerikanischen Drohne
kollidiert der Vorfall ereignete sich
wohl im internationalen Luftraum über
dem Schwarzen Meer das sowohl an
Russland als auch die Ukraine grenzt die
amerikanische Drohne des Typs Reaper
sein nach der Kollision absichtlich zum
Absturz gebracht worden berichten die
US-Streitkräfte
Claudia Beetz in Washington
jetzt zunächst mal betonen die USA dass
das kein ganz ungewöhnlicher Vorgang sei
solche Begegnungen im internationalen
Luftraum die kommen schon vor aber hier
handle es sich doch um eine
ungewöhnliche Provokation der russischen
Piloten denn die Drohne sie haben es
schon gesagt war im internationalen
Luftraum unterwegs hätte dort eine
Routine Operation durchgeführt die
russischen Piloten hätten dann zunächst
Kraftstoff über der Drohne abgelassen
und sie eben schließlich gestreift
wodurch sie von den Amerikanern vom
Himmel geholt werden musste und das ist
tatsächlich ein einmaliger Vorgang die
USA machen sehr deutlich das Russland
hier mit Absicht gehandelt habe und
verurteilen dass der Schaf ich möchte
mal die Worte aus der Erklärung zitieren
die USA bezeichnet ist als inkompetent
als unsicher als unprofessionell und sie
warnen davor dass solche aggressives
Vorgehen eben zu viel Kalkulation führen
könnte und dadurch zu ungewollter
Eskalation führen könnte die Frage ist
jetzt wie Deutschland sich dazu stellt
und dann wie die Amerikaner wie die
US-Regierung dann darauf reagiert bisher
war Präsident beiden immer sehr und
offen daran gelegen nicht zu eskalieren
wir gehen davon aus dass das auch hier
der Fall sein wird bisher hören wir dass
das
US-Außenministerium zunächst mal mit den
russischen Kollegen Kontakt aufnehmen
wolle und die Sorgen zum Ausdruck
bringen wollen Dankeschön Claudia Bates
live aus Washington zurück nach
Deutschland hier fehlt es im
Gesundheitswesen seit langem an Geld und
Personal heute hat Verdi zum
bundesweiten Warnstreik aufgerufen und
13.000 Beschäftigte aus Krankenhäusern
Pflegeeinrichtungen und dem
Rettungsdienst legten in mehreren
Bundesländern ihre Arbeit nieder die
Gewerkschaft verdi fordert 10,5% mehr
Lohn mindestens aber ein Plus von 500 €
im Monat die Arbeitgeber bieten
schrittweise fünf Prozent und eine
Einmalzahlung von 2500 Euro
wer im vergangenen Jahr ein Auto gekauft
hat musste tiefer in die Tasche greifen
Autos sind teurer geworden der Grund
dafür die steigende Inflation und das
knappe Angebot durchlieferengpässe die
Folge vW hat weniger Autos verkauft den
Gewinn aber trotzdem gesteigert um sich
für die Zukunft aufzustellen will VW
massiv in E-Mobilität investieren Fabian
Köhler berichtet zum ersten Mal
präsentiert er die Jahresergebnisse des
Konzerns VW Bus Oliver Blume seit rund 7
Monaten am Steuer in dieser Zeit hat er
den Kurs an vielen Stellen korrigiert
ja zunächst erstmal haben wir einen sehr
solides Jahr hingelegt berücksichtigen
man die ganzen externen
Herausforderungen die wir im letzten
Jahr hatten Ukraine Krieg aber auch die
Störungen im Lieferantennetzwerk Kronach
hat Downs in China wir haben nach wie
vor Herausforderungen und haben aber
einen klaren Plan dafür und deshalb
blicken wir zuversichtlich in das Jahr
2023 um 22,5%
steigert Volkswagen im vergangenen Jahr
den Gewinn auf insgesamt 2,65 Milliarden
Euro und das obwohl der Fahrzeugverkauf
um 6,8% abnahmen
eben keine Rabatte mehr weitergegeben an
die Kunden weil einfach der die
Nachfrage so hoch war und das Angebot so
gering dass man die Autos zu einem sehr
teuren Preis verkaufen konnte 180
Milliarden Euro will VW in den nächsten
Jahren investieren darunter eine
batteriefertigung in Kanada Konzern hat
in Nordamerika noch viel Potenzial wir
haben aktuell 4% Marktanteil wollen das
deutlich steigern und deshalb
unternehmen wir diese Aktivitäten die
Subventionen die es dort in Nordamerika
gibt unterstützen das natürlich und
machen dann Vorhaben deutlich
wirtschaftlicher der größte Absatzmarkt
aber bleibt China rund 35% der
vw-fahrzeuge werden hier abgesetzt würde
das Geschäft einbrechen hätte VW ein
Riesenproblem so wird in China das
Elektroauto Aldi 3 schon zum halben
Preis verkauft um konkurrenzfähig zu
bleiben
jetzt zu einem Verbrechen das selbst
erfahrene Ermittler erschüttert am
Samstag kam eine zwölfjährige in
Freudenberg Nordrhein-Westfalen von
einer Freundin nicht nach Hause am
Sonntag fand die Polizei ihre Leiche
heute gaben die Ermittler bekannt dass
das Kind wohl von zwei fast
gleichaltrigen Mädchen getötet wurde an
seinem Stern
das Leben von Luise aus Freudenberg
endet nach nur zwölf Jahren auf grausame
Art und Weise in einem Wald sie wurde
ganz offenbar umgebracht von zwei
Mädchen die sie kannte
nachdem Ergebnis der Obduktion ist das
Kind
in Folge zahlreicher Messerstiche und
des hierdurch ausgelösten
Blutverlusts verstorben 12 und 13 sind
die beiden mutmaßlichen TäterInnen
gestern haben sie die Blut Tat gestanden
sitzen nun in einem Jugendamt sie
bleiben straffrei so will es das Gesetz
Kinder unter 14 Jahren sind laut
Strafgesetzbuch schuldunfähig deswegen
können sie nicht angeklagt nicht
bestraft werden und zwar völlig egal was
sie getan haben für Sie ist auch nicht
die Staatsanwaltschaft sondern
ausschließlich das Jugendamt zuständig
und das kann als schärfste Maßnahme
beantragen Sie in einem Erziehungsheim
unterzubringen die drängende Frage was
genau passiert ist die drängende Frage
nach dem Motiv für die schreckliche Tat
bleibt heute offen sie müssen das eben
immer auch am kindlichen Alter der Tag
Verdächtigen messen und das was für
Kinder möglicherweise ein Motiv ist für
eine Tat würde sich ein Erwachsenen
unter Umständen nicht erschließen
keine Angaben zum möglichen Motiv Trauer
und Fassungslosigkeit in Freudenberg und
darüber hinaus
die unvorstellbar und kaum auszuhalten
das Kinder zu solchen Taten fähig sein
sollen
die geschilderten Details lassen uns
sehr Schaudern ja und lassen uns auch
fassungslos zurück heute waren erneut
viele Polizisten rund um den Tatort
unterwegs sie suchen nach der Tatwaffe
nachdem oder den Messern mit dem zwei
Kinder ein anderes Kind getötet haben
fit vor fifty five fit für 55 so heißt
das klimaprogramm der Europäischen Union
damit will sie bis zum Jahr 2030 die
Treibhausgasemissionen um mindestens 55%
gegenüber 1990 reduzieren Energie sparen
lässt sich zum Beispiel im Gebäude
Sektor durch Sanierung von Altbauten
darauf will das Europaparlament die
Mitgliedstaaten verpflichten
altes Haus hohe Heizkosten Käufer und
Mieter sehen das auf dem Energieausweis
ihn will die EU-Kommission nun
europaweit harmonisieren und Häuser der
untersten effizienzstufe zuerst
modernisieren dieses Prinzip übernimmt
heute die Mehrheit im Europaparlament
wenn es da eben jetzt für jeden
Mitgliedstaat die Pflicht gibt diese
Gebäude anzugehen dann sorgen wir für
niedrigere Heizkosten höhere
Wohnqualität und wir erreichen die
Klimaziele doch da endet die Harmonie
der sanierungszwang sei unnötig sagen
konservative Europa hat eigentlich seine
Hausaufgaben in der Form gemacht dass
die Pariser Klimaziele eingehalten
werden warum jetzt noch im Detail in die
Gebäude hinein regulieren aus
europäischer Sicht hier müssen
Mitgliedstaaten und Parlament sich noch
einigen was Ihnen bei einem anderen
klimagesetz schon gelungen ist Mehrheit
der Mittag für die
lastenteilungsverordnung dahinter
stecken verschärfte ein spaziele bis
2030 im Straßenverkehr beim Heizen von
Gebäuden und in der Landwirtschaft
das bedeutet dass Deutschland seine
Anstrengung in den Sektoren die nicht
von emissions Handelssystem erfasst sind
um Treibhausgase zu reduzieren deutlich
erhöhen muss Deutschland und andere
müssen 50% CO2 einsparen weil sie
wirtschaftsstärker sind Rumänien etwa
muss nur 12,7 % runter Bulgarien
10%. zusammen zeigen beide Gesetze der
Klimaschutz wird unbequemer
ich glaube wir kommen im Moment an den
Punkt wo es für den Einzelnen für jede
Bürgerin und jeden Bürger fassbar wird
bleibt es auch bezahlbar das fragen sich
Hausbesitzer die modernisieren müssen
secondhand liegt im Trend der Handel mit
gebrauchter Kleidung Büchern und Möbeln
wird immer beliebter meldet das
Statistische Bundesamt mit dem Verkauf
von gebrauchten Sachen erzielten
Privathaushalte 2021 durchschnittlich 35
Euro im Monat eine wichtige Rolle
spielen Online-Verkäufe die 15% der
Bevölkerung nutzen um gebrauchte Waren
anzubieten
zum 10 Mal in diesem Winter ziehen
schwere Unwetter über den us-sonnenstaat
Kalifornien am Freitag erst war ein
Deich gebrochen und die nächste
sturmflon ist schon angekommen viele
Regionen in Kalifornien sind überflutet
heftig und lang anhaltende Niederschläge
haben Flüsse über die Ufer treten lassen
tausende Menschen mussten ihre Häuser
verlassen und ein Ende ist nicht in
Sicht auch für die kommenden Tage sind
Unwetter angesagt
und jetzt zur Fußball Champions League
Norbert da dürfen die Fans aus Frankfurt
morgen nicht ins Stadion ja die
Präfektur Neapel hat das so angeordnet
um Fan-Ausschreitungen zu verhindern
eine sehr umstrittene Entscheidung heute
hat UEFA-Präsident Alexander jefferen
gegenüber dem ZDF das ganz als
untragbare Situation bezeichnet und
Konsequenzen angedroht
heitsgründen hatte zunächst das
italienische Innenministerium die
Anreise der deutschen Fans untersagt
nach erfolgreichem Einspruch der
Eintracht sagte dann die örtliche
Präfektur keine Tickets für Fans mit
Wohnsitz Frankfurt dagegen hatte der
Verein keinen Erfolg und bekommt heute
Unterstützung von UEFA-Präsident
Schäferin es geht nicht dass die
italienischen Behörden entscheiden das
deutsche Fans nicht zugelassen sind
diese Situation ist untragbar und wir
müssen dringend etwas dagegen tun wenn
so etwas passiert wird dort nicht
gespielt ganz einfach wir werden die
Regeln ändern nach dem neuerlichen
Verbot gegen die Eintracht Anhänger hat
der Verein inzwischen auf alle 2700
Karten verzichtet und dennoch werden
morgen hunderte Eintracht Fans in Neapel
erwartet
ja relativ problemlos dagegen sind die
Leipzig Fans in Manchester angekommen
heute abend RB gegen City im
Achtelfinale Hinspiel hatten die Sachsen
dem Favoriten immerhin ein eins zu eins
abgetrotzt nun muss Leipzig aber
Manchester besiegen um weiterzukommen in
Abwesenheit seiner erneut ausfallenden
offensivkraften kungku passt das Trainer
Marco Rose gut das Timo Werner mit
seinem Treffer gegen Gladbach gerade
wieder Selbstvertrauen tankte denn auch
beim englischen Meister Villa offensiv
agieren wenn wir uns hinten reinstellen
dann wird es irgendwann klingeln und so
bestes Spiel die Saison würde auch ganz
gut passen wie stark die Leipziger dann
sein können weiß cities Weltstar der
Bräune ganz genau das wird schwer aber
wenn du die Champions League gewinnen
willst musst du die besten Teams in
Europa schlagen
Respekt genießen Sie also schon mal in
Manchester
nun hat es die FIFA beschlossen bei der
Fußball-WM 2026 werden nicht nur
erstmals 48 Nationen statt bislang 32
teilnehmen sondern durch einen neuen
Austragungsmodus auch 104 statt 64
Spiele stattfinden
Biathlon Weltmeisterin Denise Hermann
Wick beendet ihre Karriere die
34-Jährige war schon als Langläuferin
erfolgreich dann im Biathlon Olympia
Gold in Peking und jüngst bei der
Heimweh in Oberhof Gold im Sprint am
Sonntag der letzte Auftritt von
Deutschland das beste Skijägerin beim
Weltcup in Oslo
und dann steht die Familie Mittelpunkt
hat sie gesagt
das Wetter bringt Schneeschauer und Wind
bleibt es auch mehr gleich von Katja
horneffer viertel vor zehn bringt Sie
Marietta Slomka auf den neuesten
nachrichtenstand und wir sind morgen
wieder da wenn Sie mögen danke für Ihr
Interesse und einen schönen Abend noch
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend was ist das zurzeit für ein
turbulentes Wetter gestern gab es ja zum
Teil noch Temperaturen über 20 Grad und
heute bringt das Tief Florin gleich
mehrere Kaltfronten die davon West nach
Südost über Europa hinwegziehen und
damit wird es deutlich kälter heute
Nacht sinken die Temperaturen in
Ostfriesland bis plus zwei Grad am alten
Rand geht's bis -3 Grad runter und so
wird der Regen hier in Süddeutschland im
Laufe der Nacht immer mehr in Schnee
übergehen und auch hier im Westenfeld
Schnee wie viel davon morgen früh noch
übrig ist müssen wir abwarten aber in
den Mittelgebirgen
Schauer und da können noch einzelne
Gewitter dabei sein machen Sie sich auf
Glätte gefasst durch Schnee durch
Schneematsch oder auch durch
überfrierende Nässe Morgen sind die
Schnee und Schnee Regenfälle rasch aus
Deutschland ab und so wird er Nachmittag
recht freundlich vormittags allerdings
kann es noch einzelne Gewitter geben im
nordlichen Brandenburg oder auch in
Schleswig-Holstein bei einem das heißt
aus westlichen Richtungen steigen morgen
die Temperaturen auf vier bis elf Grad
danach wird es deutlich ruhiger sonniger
bei Temperaturen von bis zu 20 Grad am
Freitag und am Samstag guten Abend